meet onyx a five-year-old eastern indigo  snake at nine feet in length eastern  integers are considered to be the  longest native snakes in the United  States even though they lack a venomous  bite they can fall victim to overzealous  rattlesnake hunters as they inhabit the  same burrows their beautiful smooth  scaled skin is a shade of bluish black  carnivorous like all snakes onyx feeds  on any small animal she can overpower  onyx may hiss or rattle her tail when  alarmed but she'll hardly ever bite like  Merce makes humans are their biggest  threat as continued urbanization has  left them threatened throughout parts of  the United States this is the eastern  indigo snake  [Music]